in this video we're going to talk about
cell division and organism growth or
another way to think about it is how do
we start with fertilization and we talk
about this in other videos but in
sexually reproducing species each
individual starts off as a cell that is
the result of the fusion between a sperm
and an egg between two gametes and each
of these gametes have half of the
genetic material needed to make that
organism
so once they fuse once the fertilization
has happened you are now diploid so
you're haploid when you have half of the
genic material as each of these
individually have each of these gametes
and then you become diploid once it's
fused
well once it's fused that fertilized egg
will then start to divide and replicate
and so a short period of time later you
might have eight cells that it has
divided into it'll first divide into two
then those two will become four those
four will become eight the eight will
become sixteen and you keep dividing and
before you know it you have trillions of
cells on the order of thirty to forty
trillion and you could create this very
handsome organism right over here
but an interesting question is how does
that division happen and are the cells
identical do they have the same
identical genetic material but if they
are how do they differentiate into all
the different types of cells that make
this handsome organism the skin cells
versus the heart cells versus the nerve
cells and this process of cell division
in which a parent cell divides into two
new daughter cells each of which is
genetically identical to the parent cell
is known as mytosis
and so let's dig into mitosis a little
bit
so let's start with two daughter cells
from a previous round of mitosis
now this would not be a human cell what
we're looking at is four chromosomes in
two pairs and the way that they've color
coded it two of these are blue and two
of these are red while human cell would
have 23 pairs or 46 chromosomes but this
is a eukaryotic cell the genetic
material is inside of the nucleus right
over here and just to understand what
these long strands are these are
chromosomes in their non-condensed form
and a chromosome you can really view as
a long strand of dna and you're going to
have segments of that dna
that code for specific proteins and
those segments are what we call genes
and in a given chromosome pair you will
code for the same genes but you might
have different versions of the same gene
maybe this gene right over here
contributes to hair color in some way
and then this other one contributes in
the same way but it might lead to a
different hair color so each of these
chromosomes in a pair we call them
homologous or homologous pairs they're
coding for the same genes they have the
same set of genes but they might have
different versions of those genes or
different alleles
so that's what we're seeing here now to
prepare for mitosis what we need to see
is
each of these chromosomes need to
replicate and once they do the cell
might look like this now it's hard to
see it here but the two copies that are
now replicated and connected at the
center we call them sister chromatids
and we can see that a little bit clearer
in the early phases of mitosis so first
we see that the chromosomes have
condensed into what we classically
imagine as chromosomes when we look at
it into a microscope this is really
happening in preparation for mitosis in
preparation for cell division and so you
see those two homologous pairs and you
could see each of those chromosomes
actually now consist of two sister
chromatids one over here
one over there as we go through mitosis
they're going to separate into
individual chromosomes that are actually
just copies of each other
now the other thing that we're seeing in
this early phase of mitosis is that the
nuclear envelope starts to break down
and we're gonna see why that's important
because we're gonna have to separate the
chromosomes now the other thing that we
see and in other future biology classes
you'll go into much more detail is the
mitotic spindle is starting to form
now we don't have to go into all the
details of the different parts of the
mitotic spindle but imagine a bunch of
structures made primarily by protein
that are actually going to act to allow
the mitosis to happen to grab the
chromosomes to pull them apart to allow
the cell to change its shape so that
it'll eventually be able to divide
but after that we go into the middle
phase of mitosis
so as we enter into the middle phases of
mitosis we can see now that the
chromosomes are aligned at the center
and they've actually now been attached
to the mitotic spindle which is going to
be important because that's the
machinery that's going to pull them
apart and bring them to the different
sides of the cell and as we continue
through the middle phases of mitosis we
see that right over there
that those sister chromatids are now
pulled apart and they are copies of each
other they became copies of each other
back here where the dna originally
replicated when it wasn't in its
condensed form
but i think you see where this is going
as the mitotic spindle pulls on these
chromosomes we then enter into the late
phases of mitosis and you can see here
that the sister chromatids which are now
individual chromosomes have been pulled
to either side of that now elongated
cell
you can see that once they're there a
nuclear envelope begins to form again on
either side and then the mitotic spindle
breaks down and the splitting of the
cytoplasm finally into two daughter
cells is known as cytokinesis so it's
pretty mind-boggling to realize that
this is going on in your body
continuously and this is what allowed
all of us to start as a single-celled
organism a fertilized egg and become an
organism made up of tens of trillions of
cells
now i haven't gone into detail yet even
though the great majority of our cells
have the exact same genetics they are
actually able to differentiate express
different parts of the genetics based on
the roles that they need to play but we
will talk about that in future videos
it's also important to realize that
mitosis isn't just about growing an
organism it's also about maintaining an
organism and doing tissue repair for an
organism so i'll leave you there look at
your hands look at your arms look in the
mirror and just realize that you are an
organism of 30 to 40 trillion cells that
all start with one cell through many
many many rounds of mitosis